detenido en una redada en su lujosa
Villa de bucarest tras al parecer
delatar su propia ubicación el polémico
influencer Andrew tate fue detenido el
viernes por las autoridades rumanas
acusado de trata de personas violación y
pertenencia a banda criminal el ex
Kickboxer británico que se trasladó a
rumania hace cinco años Fue detenido
junto a su hermano y dos ciudadanos
locales
las autoridades difundieron un vídeo de
la redada en la que se veían pistolas
cuchillos y dinero
tate saltó a la fama cuando fue
expulsado desde el reality británico
gran hermano por un vídeo en el que
aparecía agrediendo una mujer después se
hizo famosa por sus polémicas opiniones
en internet fue expulsado de Twitter por
afirmar que las mujeres debían asumir la
responsabilidad de ser violadas otras
redes sociales como YouTube Facebook
Instagram y tiktok también lo han
expulsado sus publicaciones en otros
sitios web que promueven la misoginia
tienen millones de visitas Aunque
recientemente se le permite volver a
Twitter tras la adquisición de elon musk
esta semana saltó a los titulares tras
enzarzarse en una guerra verbal en la
red social con la activista climática
greta thunberg
por favor tráeme pizza y asegúrate que
las cajas no sean reciclables
Este vídeo dentro de la discusión donde
se detecta la marca rumana de pizzas
presuntamente fue el indicio que la
policía tuvo para avanzar en el arresto
y obviamente provocó la irónica reacción
de tumberg
las autoridades rumanas confirmaron en
un comunicado que sería detenido durante
24 horas y está siendo investigado
penalmente en el país desde abril